Hi,
welcome to toxic Google and Cambridge,
Massachusetts.
And,
uh,
not today.
I'm delighted to introduce a two for one topic.
Um,
first,
uh,
is,
Abraham Flexner,
who was the person that I think we should all know better.
Uh,
the first,
uh,
director of the institute at Princeton and one of the people responsible for
bringing a Albert Einstein to this country among many other things,
a very famous in his time,
a front page of which were the New York Times.
And we seem to have forgotten about him.
Fascinating person,
the author of the original classic essay and here to comment and expand on that.
Uh,
Robert Diagraph,
the current Director Institute an advanced studies at Princeton,
um,
certainly,
uh,
accomplished scientist and,
and there's an own right,
um,
director and Leon [inaudible] professor at the Institute since 2012.
Mathematical physicist,
well known for,
uh,
a string theory and also the advancement of,
of scientific education.
And,
uh,
so he's,
I'm a past president of the Royal Netherlands Academy of Arts and Sciences in
that capacity,
uh,
an advisor to the,
the Dutch government,
um,
advocate for the science and the arts.
Um,
he has received the spinosa price prize,
the highest scientific award in the Netherlands,
and has been named a night to the order of the Netherlands lion member of the
American Academy of Arts and Sciences and the American philosophical society.
Um,
so a heartfelt welcome Robert.
Thank you so much.
Thank you Richard.
And a great pleasure to talk here.
A about a very small book.
So a,
it take you,
I think only an hour to read,
but I think it's a small book on a very large topic,
namely the,
uh,
the role that basic research place in our lives.
And,
uh,
in some sense on deeper themes like curiosity and imagination.
Um,
it's great to be a coauthor with Abraham Flexner who indeed needs,
I think in some sense we have to resurrect his legacy.
And in indeed,
he was famous for bringing Albert Einstein to the,
uh,
to the institute.
So,
uh,
when,
this book came out and thought it would be good idea to see where we can have a
blurb for Mine Stein about to book because they must have known Flexner well.
So I was a visioning Einstein.
I really recommend that book I think was perfect occasion to do so.
So then I looked in the ultimate quotable Einstein,
which has almost 600 pages of Einstein quotations on everything,
but it was heading think about Flexner and it was one quotation and it said,
uh,
one of my few enemies.
So I that I've lost my proposal to have on the book ethic,
but,
uh,
we didn't go there.
Um,
Flexner wrote this essay,
the usefulness of useless knowledge,
which has a catching title.
Um,
uh,
you worked on it for many years,
in fact,
almost two decades.
It was finally published in October,
1939 in Harper's magazine.
And it's interesting just to see what was relevant in October 39.
You see,
uh,
one of the issues here where all the bus a article about conscious and more
time,
but it was also equally important article and why can't we have perfect teeth or
old people arising natural problems.
So,
uh,
it's,
the world was in crisis,
but in some sense it's still remarkable that he was writing about the use of
basic research,
the usefulness of basic research in that time.
And in this book,
I actually,
I started to boot by explaining the 39 were special too because it was actually
the year when the world's fair came to New York.
And the theme was the world of tomorrow,
in fact,
that we've turned the 1964.
Um,
but it wasn't queens and it really,
it was a wave where many people could meet new technology.
For instance,
the first television broadcast was there at that point that were 200 television
sets.
And the first live broadcast was the opening speech of President Roosevelt,
the dishwasher,
the fax machine.
They were all introduced to the American audience for the first time.
Uh,
on the other hand,
the was things of days long past,
for instance,
kind of a beauty pageant of steam engines.
Um,
and another thing,
the first robot was introduced,
it's nameless electro.
He could smoke a cigarette and he had a little,
uh,
robot.
A dog sparky did a could play with and he would see him,
uh,
performing or,
yeah,
not that impressive,
but I think it was actually his,
the voice,
uh,
walls by playing a gramophone records.
So all this was 1939 technology,
but actually it was the second opening speech and that was by Albert Einstein.
Albert Einstein decided to talk about cosmic rays and,
um,
it has been described as a comedy of error because the trick was that the cosmic
rays particles coming from the universe were captured in the Hayden Planetarium
in Manhattan,
then sent by telephone,
whatever that mean to the fairgrounds.
And when the 10th cosmic ray was captured,
a big switch were thrown and then the fuse blew and the whole room turned pitch
dark.
Uh,
and the New York Times then report the next day.
Dot.
The audience left this kind of exposition about science to apply to go to
something they could applaud.
So it was kind of not a great success.
Um,
but,
uh,
I think it's an amazing,
because Einstein was talking about the world of tomorrow,
but he didn't mention two topics.
It didn't mention nuclear power,
nuclear energy,
and he didn't mention computers.
And both of them actually where I death point really developed under his own
eyes in the Institute for Advanced Study,
uh,
that was set up by Abraham Flexner.
So the institute was set up and founded the 1930 to first professors came in
1933,
a as a kind of an island of paradise for scholars,
uh,
as this New York Times magazine article describes seeking internal truth in a
world of chaos.
Um,
but,
uh,
little did Einstein or Flexner,
who was the first director realized that he was actually creating these kind of
terrific developments that would totally change the world.
So only a few months later,
the opening of the world's fair was,
I think in April and August 39,
Einstein would write his famous letter to get together with Leo Szilard,
uh,
asking President Roosevelt to develop the atomic bomb.
And the Manhattan project basically come,
got underway in October 39 flection essay do this referred bleakly to,
uh,
atomic power.
But he wasn't aware.
I think that this was kind of happening.
Uh,
another development in the 1930s was that Princeton became a center for
mathematical logic church.
Vernoy Mun girdle Turing of course was a Grad student there.
And for Norman actually,
uh,
working on the abstract computing machine proving mathematical theorems realized
a few years later that,
uh,
building,
an electronic computer as you know,
very well,
it's much more efficient using the [inaudible] architecture that is to say
allowed to compute it to be programmable.
And he built actually the first a prototype of that at the institute.
Here you see him with Oppenheimer and the integration of the ias machine,
it's quite remarkable thing.
It has a 30 by 32 memory.
It was built for more surplus material because of course you are not going to
spend this,
uh,
real money on,
on,
on building this computer.
And in fact,
it was a triple helix efforts because it was supported both by philanthropy by,
uh,
the war effort and,
by companies RCA and later IBM.
In fact,
the norm on that only did huge simulations of the hydrogen bomb.
He also used that computer to do the first electronic weather forecast.
This and the other,
the machine and pen.
So this is the first computerized weather prediction from January,
1949 you'd like to indicate it took that these days,
48 hours to predict tomorrow's wetter.
So,
um,
it was yesterday's retro actually,
whichever is pretty good to on the 30 by 32 bit machine and this institute,
which was supposed to be as far removed from reality as possible hats.
You know,
here's the floor plan in 1948 that Einstein being the father of the peace
movement,
it had [inaudible] and being a part of your role model for doctor strange
Strangelove and you know,
uh,
building the coldest of cold warriors and Oppenheimer who was kind of caught in
between.
So it's the perfect case to demonstrate the title,
a Flexner that,
you know,
this is kind of useless knowledge,
whether it's abstract mathematical logic or understanding the quantum mechanics
of atomic new fly could have incredible useful and also dangerous consequences.
So who was Abraham Flexner does men that we basically forgot about it.
So he was born in a poor Jewish family,
immigrant family in 1866 and saint Louis.
He had nine siblings.
Three brothers became pretty famous.
Simon Flexner,
who was the first director of the Rockefeller Institute,
now Rockefeller University,
it was a medical doctor.
Bernard flexible is very seriously involved in politics and Abraham Flexner.
He was the one who was able to go to Johns Hopkins University at a very young
age at age 17.
Graduated in classics in two years.
Went to start back to Saint Louis,
created but became a high school teacher.
Uh,
became notorious because he was failing at one year is full class,
which actually made the headlines in the local newspaper.
Started when he was age 23 years old in high school,
and then became famous by the so-called Flexner report report.
He issued in 1910 that looked at all 155 medical schools in the u s and
effectively led to the closure of 120 of them medical education.
That time was a disaster.
It was for profit.
Uh,
it's,
that wasn't an undergraduate course.
Students would not see any patients ever.
Just basically a scam.
And,
uh,
he,
minces no words.
I think Chicago is described as the plague spots of the country,
but even very established medical schools like here at Harvard,
they essentially closed down and started again Johns Hopkins,
which was the first modern research university.
It was the only one,
one of the few,
I think that also lighting example and then flex and start to think about a
universities too.
And it became a very influential thinker about modern American universities,
uh,
criticizing.
They're kind of shallowness the lack of research culture in uh,
universities in 1920s and thirties.
He's,
he,
for instance,
describing Columbia and uh,
telling that,
you know,
we can see that Columbia,
that point offered courses impractical poultry raising.
So this was the early thirties.
This was a time that they know are people really looking for jobs.
And then came the moment,
which really made him,
uh,
move from an abstract theoretical critique to actually do something.
He was able to start the institute for advanced study thanks to a wonderful
grant by the Bamberger family who sold the department store.
They had in Newark Department Store in 1929 a few weeks before the Wall Street
crash.
So they were one of the few philanthropies that had actually had cash.
Um,
and that actually the institute became quite influential because geopolitics
intervenes of course 1933 certainly there's this wonderful group of German
scholars,
Jewish Germans,
callers,
political refugees who were in search of the home and the institute became kind
of an Ellis Island,
uh,
attracting scholars from across the world.
Here you see some of the,
it's difficult to read very small grants we're giving to these great names.
So you could kind of by,
so to say,
but could girdle a think for $1,200 or the greatest logicians from the last 2000
years or stand Tulum,
the Polish mathematician who designed the hydrogen bomb.
I think he has an 800 and the joke is that there was something there where
again,
the Bamberger family that had this department store was again,
a dealing in distressed merchandise.
But now it's us.
And,
uh,
Flexner,
he writes in 1939,
I think very perceptively.
There's 50 years from now,
historians looking backwards,
we'll,
if we act with courage and imagination report that during our time the center of
gravity is scholarship,
moved across the Atlantic to the United States.
And it's good to remind ourselves that the centers of scholarship have moved
across the globe,
uh,
through the centuries.
Um,
he makes a perfect argument and as I said,
you know,
in the,
as a setting interdiction,
when he dies in 1959,
the New York Times writes actually,
uh,
that,
no other American of his time has contributed more to the welfare of this
country and humanity in general.
So a quite remarkable to see that somebody was central arch reputation.
Um,
it's in some sense for government and I think he should not be because the
argument he makes is timeless.
It's the argument about the usefulness of useless knowledge.
He spends a lot of time arguing for,
it's about electromagnetism,
Faraday and Maxwell,
uh,
this,
this famous quote of sure.
But it's true that when the British Chancellor of the exchequer visited Ferriday
days lap and ask her what this good a professor Ferriday oldest electricity's
had,
I've no idea,
but one day,
sure you will tax it.
And he was right.
Uh,
you could say that these days,
electricity,
everything is governed by electricity.
Um,
another example,
uh,
quantum mechanics.
So if you think of the birth of quantum mechanics,
so muck Splunk famously said that there was an act of desperation.
You really want to save the laws of physics and he had to do this crazy thing.
He wants to be willing to make any offer to the principals in physics that I
then held.
Uh,
it doesn't to esoteric subject for just a handful of people.
And of course these days it's estimate that 30% of GDP,
but it could be higher,
isn't some sense directly connected to the results of quantum mechanics where
it's integrated circuits,
nanomaterials,
lasers.
And of course with the advent of quantum computing,
this only will increase this percentage,
uh,
the life sciences.
Oh,
I think any breakthrough we have seen in life sciences,
whether it's the discovery of the structure of DNA,
uh,
of gene genetic code,
a gene editing at all was curiosity driven research.
And perhaps the biggest story in the last few hundred years has been a
tremendous progress in a health.
So the fact that lifespan life expectancy in the west basically tripled in 250
years.
It's amazing fact of history.
It's not sure where it's taught in history causes because it's something that
takes place over centuries.
But because of hygiene and medical research that actually made a tremendous
impact on the lives of everyone.
Uh,
and in fact there was another thing which I,
that will be the next book would be about the uselessness of the usefulness of
useless knowledge because it's like a third order effect.
And that this very practical thing get give rise again to basic research.
And my favorite example is super conductivity superconductivity was discovered
in 1911.
If you cool materials very called electric current starts to go basically at no
cost.
Uh,
which means that you can build very strong magnets while the strong magnets of
course are used in transportation,
but they also used in Fmri scanners.
And you could think of the whole field of neuroscience only could develop
because of these incredible progress in magnets.
And these days or many quantum computer elements also of course really use these
magnets and he's very kind of low temperatures.
But the best example,
the lowest,
the,
the place we think in the universe that is the coldest place in the universe and
it has the largest magnet is uh,
actually the large Hadron collider in certain Geneva.
And,
um,
it's because of the magnet technology and the superconductivity being used there
that actually led to the discovery of the Higgs Boson.
And remarkable,
the theory behind the Higgs Boson is a very close relatives to the theory of,
of the Sucre conductivity.
So in some sense we went through a full cycle from an abstract physical
discovery through applications back to fundamental physics.
And it's good to remind that Peter Higgs,
uh,
even in,
in physics itself,
there are long timeline snow.
It took 50 years from the original idea to the Nobel prize.
So the first 10,
first decade,
he was totally ignored.
Then it was a decade where people really read the paper and we've got an
interested then another decade designing the machine,
a decade building the machine and a decade running the machine.
And when Peter Higgs at the announcement said,
with tears in his eyes that he was happy to see the discovery in his lifetime,
um,
I think it was 84 at that time,
that he was very serious.
I was,
could easily have took another decade or decade or two.
Uh,
another good example is the discovery of gravitational waves that we will have
witnessed.
Uh,
uh,
roughly,
was announced a year ago a,
but the discovery was in September,
2015.
That was a hundred year prediction where Albert Einstein,
so he didn't leave live to actually see this.
But of course we as a,
as a,
as a human society we did.
I always like to think,
you know,
in some sense cosmologists are a good framework because they know exactly what
they don't know.
As you know,
in cosmology,
we know that roughly 5% of the contents of the universe is known as exists,
have no material,
there's 95% still to be discovered.
And I think this is exactly,
uh,
what,
cosmologies want to do.
So I feel,
I mean in basic science we are a little bit like the old explorers.
If it has these kind of wonderful maps,
part of it was covered,
but then it was a large part which was unknown.
And these cartographers would draw these kind of sea monsters in it,
right?
Because that's,
you know,
I am imagination fills that empty space.
But the role of basic science is to explore this.
And I could actually,
I want to argue,
and I think you are probably preaching to the choir here,
but it's that we are in some sense more exciting moment in a time of basic
research because you know,
off,
you could frame it like this.
What is the most important thing ever discovered in science?
And one way to phrase this about the world would kind of disappear and you're
still able to communicate one line,
say one Twitter message to the next generation.
What would the hint you would give to the next generation of,
of budding scientist?
And my line would actually be a this,
that all matter of the earth and the cosmos consist of particles a billion times
smaller than everyday object.
The fact that we have discovered the building blocks of matter of life is
incredibly important.
Uh,
I was thinking,
I suppose you give a child a toy,
you can give it a metal car or one made of Lego blocks.
And if you go back to the child to two children a few weeks later,
the one who was getting the,
the legal actually would build something else.
So I think actually we are now in a phase where it's really a matter of our,
what are we going to build now that we discovered the building blocks of nature.
And we see this,
you know,
in,
in the material sciences where now we can basically build materials atom by
atom.
You see this in life sciences where we have,
uh,
synthetic biology can produce things that no only imagination can think of.
So would like to say,
you know,
in the old model where the sciences are exploring nature and we kind of know
what we don't know.
So we want to cover the whole map.
Uh,
we are now in a stage of development where we are not looking at nature,
what we building nature ourselves.
So it's basically the space of everything we can make and how we find our ways
in this kind of vast space.
And I think that that is the exciting moment where basic research is.
So why would you have basic research?
And I think we can raise,
revisit flexing his argument.
Well,
I think the first and foremost thing to say is that clearly we want to argue
that knowledge,
you know,
in an office itself is incredibly important.
Uh,
and that's true for the sciences.
That's true for the humanities.
It's true for the arts,
but there are some extra layers.
And that's exactly where Flexner and I'm trying to add to it is we know that's a
basic science,
develops new tools and techniques.
As a particle physicist,
I'm a oblige then to say that the worldwide web was developed in terms of Co
could we facilitate the communications through thousands and thousands of
particle physicist to an original?
When are they able to read each other's rap pages,
but also right on the cheaters on,
on the web pages.
Uh,
then of course it's attracting the best minds who then can go out again here I
have to say the theoretical physicists went into the financial markets and
basically destroyed the world.
I think so it should be giving credit to death.
Um,
also important to realize is certainly here.
I think as,
as you know,
it's very difficult to capture the full profits of basic research because they
will flow across disciplines.
They flow across regions,
across countries,
across generations.
And so in many ways it's a true public boot,
uh,
ecommerce to have not done a good job.
It putting the right numbers there.
So if you ask any economist,
what is the investment,
the return on investment of a dollar spent on basic research,
you get all kinds of numbers between four and 15.
But it's a big multiplier.
And I would wish that some,
since we could argue more particular,
I think because it's without a doubt,
as I said,
it's a public good and it's something that in the end I think needs to be
publicly supportive.
And of course it leads to plenty of innovation startups.
And you know,
here in MIT,
close to MIT,
we are some sense that,
uh,
kind of the,
the,
the very epicenter of this tremendous effort.
And,
uh,
and you,
you are some sentence,
the embodiment,
this Google is of course an embodiment of this.
Um,
but if you see,
you know,
how federal and,
uh,
for instance,
support for research has developed and I can imagine a Flexner coming back and
tell us,
okay,
tell us what happened in the,
in the intervening years.
And the first part of my story would be best.
Very positive.
Of course.
No,
he has seen that after World War Two,
uh,
there was this terrific,
current and of support.
Uh,
there was the famous report by Vulva Bush Science,
the endless frontier that led to the,
to the creation to national science foundation,
not only in this country but across the world,
uh,
and currently increase in basic research,
with and not that many strings attached.
And that kind of peaked as a,
as you see on this graph as a percentage of GDP around 64,
which was the height both of the Cold War and the space race.
And then it went down and it has been basically a steady decline.
It's something even no,
uh,
only vaguely correlated with the political color of the administration.
And we see this,
uh,
and you see that in some sense the,
the defense and non defense components have been roughly in balance.
So roughly 50% of what this country spends on research and development will be
defense oriented.
The other one is not.
If you look,
for instance,
at the National Institute of Health in real dollars,
apart from the stimulus money in 2009,
it had basically declined by roughly 20,
25% over the last 15 years.
And of course this point as you know very well,
uh,
it's,
it's threatened by even more severe cuts,
uh,
with the,
the presence,
so called skinny budget of the current administration.
But this had been Maureen trends.
Uh,
if you look at the share of r and d expenditure by the various resources you see
also that,
you know,
uh,
the corporate world,
in some sense has never been a very,
very strongly supportive with roughly now Spence,
I think 6% of all r and d money on basic research.
So it's typically something that,
uh,
where public funding and philanthropy and universities play an incredible role.
And if you talk to the next generation young scientist,
there's a lot of complaint end.
They are worrying about job,
uh,
about grants,
about jobs.
It turns out that the kind of success rates for grant application for young
scientists at this time is roughly half of what it was,
what it was in the early eighties.
So,
uh,
in some sense the senior scientist around in academia and elsewhere,
we're living in a much better time and are still in a much better position I
think in terms of the next generations.
So why,
uh,
this kind of lack of success,
while the arguments that Flexner makes it so powerful and I think it's good to
have a conversation about this,
there are many forces that are,
uh,
I think at fault.
Uh,
definitely I think,
you know,
this shorter attention span of politicians of company is driving this.
But also there's a thing that I would like to call the knowledge paradox because
how does science interacts with society?
And you know,
this is kind of a paradox that whatever we do in research,
we can dig deeper and some,
so the results of research are more difficult to understand.
Now,
if you really want to understand what's happening,
you know,
in electronic a appliance or in a new drug,
you have to know a lot of detail.
So in some sense it moves infinitely far away.
On the other hand,
the products of science are everywhere around us,
no in,
uh,
in our pockets,
in our phones,
in our medicines,
everywhere.
So I feel this kind of interface between science and society becomes this kind
of fractal thing.
It's kind of signs being atomized there.
This is kind of little pockets of knowledge,
very specialized and they're everywhere around us,
but they become basically invisible and it's much more difficult to make the
case,
I think these days.
Um,
and this is something that,
you know,
a Flexner,
uh,
was very much aware of it and I think the most important point that he makes in
the book,
and I want to kind of finish on that,
on that note,
on that theme is curiosity.
Uh,
you know,
he makes basically another point.
He says,
this is wonderful ability of human beings to see things that are in there,
to imagine things that aren't easily to imagine for most of us.
And it's this ability that,
uh,
is so powerful and it actually is being used,
whether it be used in companies,
in,
in academic world or an education.
I think that actually I feel is in some sense,
perhaps the most important argument why we have to create these kind of
environments as Flexner writes,
curiosity,
which may or may not eventually,
uh,
eventually there's something useful,
although it's good to,
somebody said,
you know,
you have,
we have to distinguish applied research and not yet applied research because how
can you argue that something is totally useless and will be forever useless?
Uh,
you never know.
For instance,
a hundred years ago,
number theorists,
we're very proud to,
their field was totally useless.
And the beauty of the prime numbers.
And now because of coding actually number theories at the very center of
Cybersecurity,
et Cetera.
I have one colleague who says he wants to improve some big math theorem
factorization of prime numbers so that he can liberate his subjects from the
chains of applicability and make it again,
useless.
Uh,
so you never know,
but curiosity is Flexner writes,
it goes back,
you know,
it's outstanding characteristic of more than thinking.
It goes back to Galileo,
Bacon,
Newton,
and as much as we absolutely unhampered and have a little anecdote,
uh,
this is,
Jacobi was fun at half.
He was a chemist.
In fact,
he was the first one to win the Nobel prize in Chemistry.
He was Dutch show at that point.
The Dutch totally cornered the market of Nobel prizes in chemistry.
And in fact,
his big insight was that molecules per three dimensional.
Now this will say if you take a molecule,
you look at this mirror image might be different molecule and it might have
different chemical reactions.
That's,
that's kind of a new concept.
In fact,
you'll see some someone's,
the models in which he was kind of demonstrating this.
Um,
and uh,
he was pretty famous.
I actually went to a high school which has a big statue to him,
so I've passed that,
that statue,
uh,
every day I think you were be,
we are not,
uh,
you know,
honoring our scientific heroes in that fashion anymore.
Um,
and she would just kind of chiral molecules was a very important thing.
It's to know,
as you know,
all of life sciences depends on the current reality of these molecules from DNA
down.
But the point was,
dad,
you know,
he was criticized as,
as,
as a scientist,
but as a Jew,
young scientist by his seniors that he didn't use too much imagination.
I think he is at that point,
he was working at the veterinary school and one colleague said,
well,
you just consider it more comfortable to Mount Pegosys you to flying horse and
just go and fly to the Mount Parnassus and just declare of things.
Or instead of the painstaking me,
the riving do results.
And from his whole for so upset by the criticism that the money was finally made
a professor,
his inaugural lecture was about imagination in science and he approached the
subject scientifically.
So we took a sample off the 200 most famous scientist of last 200 years and put
them in three categories.
The first category was scientist with imagine it without imagination,
so no interest in the arts and poetry and painting music.
The second was those with imagination and there was a third category,
but he called scientists with perverse imagination.
That is,
uh,
the wanted to go to al comedian wants to do metaphysical stuff,
et cetera.
And if fact in that category,
it's a,
contains a deck cards like needs Newton on pair a Wallace.
So,
uh,
actually it's the real famous scientists are in death and that buckets and you
know,
a Newton famously became an alchemist.
Then you can perhaps understand why,
you know,
because he,
he,
uh,
somebody sat,
Newton must have been the happiest person,
whoever lifts in the history of the planet because only one person can be the
first to discover that there was a system in the world.
Uh,
and uh,
of course he some sense invented modern,
deterministic science and the fact that you,
if you have unified the laws of gravity for the heavenly bodies and on earth and
funded fundamental laws of mechanics,
why not also fun?
Find a fundamental laws of history,
of religion,
of alchemy.
Uh,
and you know,
you can make gold out of lads.
It only takes a nuclear reactions.
Those of us done done 10 years ago.
So,
um,
it's uh,
clearly,
you know,
he,
his Emma imagination reached further than a,
that the science of his time would allow an Einstein also famous sent you that
imagination is more important than knowledge for knowledge is limited to all we
know and understandable image generation embraces the entire world.
Put a picture of a mechanism of a young eyes said here,
because you all know the story that Einstein,
I think it was five year olds,
it was given a mechanism and he was fascinated.
Well a Kompass fascinated that the needle was always pointing in the right
direction.
But then he also describes that he walked with the compass through the room and
you know,
to wait a moment,
there must be something that the steering the compass.
So as a five year old,
he was basically in discovering the magnetic fields.
And of course,
you know,
in some sense it's great contribution to science was discovered the
gravitational fields and think of it as something permeating all space.
Uh,
so he clearly had a very,
very bright imagination at a young age.
And I think we not doing enough to stimulate imagination and creativity.
This,
this famous test you have undoubtedly read about it,
which a test that's done with a NASA engineers and you know,
2% of them pass the test.
And then it was one person who said,
well,
let's take the test to five year olds and see how they do.
And the 90th 98% pass at 10 year old,
only 30% of 15 years,
12%.
So I think actually,
I mean one instruction we should give to people in the education fields don't
touch that button.
You know,
at the end the imagination properties turned on at the very beginning.
And we are,
we put a lot of effort in and learning skills to imagine and create and often
then at universities and other research institutes,
we work very hard to relearn these kinds of qualities.
And this might be something I feel that,
uh,
the only point where I,
when my defer,
my points differ.
This Flexner Flexner felt that basic research scholarship is good as it is.
So scientists who rewarded and just let them do whatever they will do.
In some sense he was an [inaudible].
No.
When,
uh,
Einstein came to the institute in 1933,
he was invited by President Roosevelt to the White House.
A Flexner intercepted that letter and he wrote back,
well,
uh,
you will understand professor Einstein is a very important scientist.
He's very busy and he has to focus on this research.
Uh,
I signed,
was very upset when this happens and made himself be reinvited.
He also then opened his own meal.
And this might actually be the reason why we have the slightly negative,
uh,
quotes about Flexner.
Uh,
so it didn't go along very well.
And I think Einstein actually,
it wasn't in some sense a perfect example,
somebody who was able to reach a large audience and spoke when he became the
canonical scientists,
not only because of the scientific work,
but also think has moral compass and how we,
uh,
one thing I learned,
to my surprise,
but being in Princeton is that he spent a lot of time on this wonderful
quotations.
You might think,
oh,
it just came up with that,
you know,
he thought about it and he,
he,
he's coped with them just as the sculpted his mathematical equations and what
are you were done,
you would cut them out and put them in a wooden box.
So I would like to say he was actually using Twitter,
uh,
50 years before,
before it was discovered.
And I think this is something that we can know.
I think there's a,
a large audience that we can reach out to and,
um,
want to close with one final anecdote,
which is that,
uh,
now a few years ago I wasn't on Dutch television and,
it just had loans,
a website with experiments for young children.
And,
uh,
it's such a pretty popular website.
And,
uh,
and they asked me,
can you do an experiment?
So I should have brought it here,
but it's an experiment.
You can do it at home.
She would take a balloon filled with water and then hold it a above somebody,
uh,
hats and then take a lighter or a match and tried to burn a hole in it,
and will not work.
Uh,
and I did it and then I explained why.
He said,
well,
you know,
if you have an empty kettle on the stove,
it gets hot very fast.
If it's filled with water,
it takes a lot of time,
has to do with thermodynamic properties of water.
He'd capacity.
That's why if you live close to the sea,
and if a moderate climate,
so I had my little spiel and explain some basic physics.
So I felt very happy with that.
And the next morning get an email from a very,
very distinguished that physicists,
they said,
rob,
Robert,
I liked,
I saw you on television.
I like the experiments,
but you explanation was of course,
totally wrong.
So I get this sinking feeling,
you know,
uh,
he never,
he'll never speak out.
And then he said,
no,
no.
You didn't show the experiments to explain sermon and attics.
You did shogi experiments to explain the phenomena of a law of nature.
This is scientific principle that's for beat you to burn the whole.
And uh,
that's why you know that this party trick works.
And that actually is something that you should have said.
And I think it's right now if you ask me if this month thing,
if I could wave a magic wand and make everybody in the world understand one
thing from signs,
what would you pick?
Um,
I'm probably wouldn't be able to do within the one tweet,
but I would like to have everybody understand the scientific method to fact that
are,
you can do experiments,
you can learn about facts,
you can have some idea.
It can disprove it.
You learn again,
you do another experiment.
You've again and uh,
and that's,
uh,
has been incredibly successful method and I think that's something that we can
spread and it's something that people should know.
So I feel this perhaps the way to kind of bridge this gap that I've,
I worry about that we have this terrific research.
And I said,
I don't think they're an Afa had been more opportunities there.
Now I think every scientist and every time the history of science has said this
and they were all right because it's just a growing,
it's an exponential growth in function.
So it's getting better and better and better.
We are in this terrific moment,
but we aren't able to make the case.
And in some sense society is kind of starting to decouple and I think we have to
cross bridge and again make the case that uh,
that Flexner makes,
uh,
an extremely powerful way.
And um,
so perhaps I want to kind of end by just because we are a kind of a complicated
political situation here and across the world,
but it reminds you to flex and wrote about all of this in October 39,
which was,
as I said,
not the best of times.
So this is the way he opens the essay.
Is it not a curious fact that in a world steeped and in racial hatred with
threatened civilization itself,
men and women,
old and young detach themselves wholly or partly from the Aaron Greek current of
daily life to devote themselves to the cultivation of beauty,
to the extension of knowledge,
to the cure of disease,
to remuneration of suffering.
Just as though fanatics,
we're not simultaneously engaged in spreading pain in,
uh,
ugliness and suffering.
The world has always been a sorry and confused sort of place.
Yet poets and artists and scientists have ignored the factors that woot if
attended to paralyze them.
So I think these are very wise words.
They are,
they should be right again.
So I'm very happy that I'm now on this kind of book tour.
[inaudible] a famous or coauthor Abraham Flexner.
Thank you very much.
Hmm.
Wonderful talk and the questions.
Thank you for the fascinating talk.
As you say,
you're preaching to the choir here.
Yes,
we all came through one or another higher institute of Education.
We've been propagandized about this quite successfully.
We all believe it.
And I'm not saying I don't.
Um,
but one question that's unclear,
it's clear that the curiosity is a driver for many things,
but in modern society,
research including basic research has become an industry and flexor in some
sense in invented that.
Yeah.
Street,
uh,
with one small institute.
So when we now have,
I don't know what it is,
millions of people engaged in basic and not so basic research.
How do we as a society decide how to spend,
how much money to spend on that research?
Why do we believe that distinguished professors of physics should have upper
middle class lifestyles and not just be driven by their curiosity and maybe a
funding for their equipment?
Uh,
how do we think about these things?
And I,
and I say this as a member of,
of the class that benefits from all this.
Of course.
No,
it's a very good question.
And it's,
I mean,
in,
in in some sense in,
in its basic form would be indeed how much time and money and energy should be
spent on these efforts.
And one thing I found kind of surprising is that I know even as a society,
uh,
nope going,
we made lots of progress.
You said No.
Some sense we've seen this whole architecture of the scientific enterprise being
built.
We didn't spend that much time arguing about why this particular architecture.
Now what are the economic arguments,
uh,
how are we,
I'm advocating in the book of what you need is a kind of a well balanced
portfolio of research projects.
How do we look at this?
I think actually,
honestly we look in a more deliberate and sensible way at financial investments
and how they are.
How much risk do you want to take?
How much correlation do you want between the various issues?
How much long term,
how much shorter than we do in research.
Because in some sense it's,
no,
it's a,
it's a little bit fly by your pants and intuitive.
Uh,
one thing we see is that these days there are a lot of quantify the quantifiable
metrics,
but they have serious problems because what we see is that what they do,
they drive research around the world all to the same spots.
So we get this kind of regression to the mean and a lot of boring research is
being done.
So I don't have the answer,
but I think we should have a serious conversation about these issues also about
now what is the percentage,
so to say,
what is the right percentage to spend?
I know in this company you're can,
if you want,
spend 20% on other projects,
at least it's a number.
So I think society's haven't put a number there.
They,
I think the first approximation good is to take the world average or something.
And that's often how we argue are we behind or a ahead of our competitors.
But I think we need a serious discussion about this.
And I think,
you know,
in certain enterprises,
I think particularly in the life sciences,
the current architecture is totally unsustainable.
No,
if you have a,
it's been indicated they've,
every researcher kind of breeds 10 more that then have their own,
their research group.
You get an exponential function.
That's clearly these days.
If you are life scientists who are in your mid thirties forties when you get
your first,
typically your first NIH grant,
so you basically reach independence at age 45 that's not a very attractive.
Uh,
and so I think that we need more research about that.
We have sharp thinking,
what is the role of corporations or philanthropy who can do what and why as a
society do we value this?
And I said,
you know,
I'm kind of disappointed that economists have had such great difficulty putting
kind of numbers.
They're asked by the way they have in the more broader field of education,
it's very difficult to make the case there.
What,
how does an investment in your education,
and they were kind of education lead to,
uh,
for instance your personal gains.
But I think here it's really as a society that we have to have and it's a
running target,
so to say,
because,
uh,
science itself,
if developing it's,
it's grown and become more international.
Uh,
some of the costs of the experiments are really becoming very large.
And,
uh,
and I feel that we spent very little time discussing this.
We also spend very little time arguing for science.
Somebody once told me that the commercial product with the smallest advertising
budgets is kitchen salt.
Now,
I've never seen a commercial about kitchen salt.
I think,
uh,
but at science spends less in advertising.
Uh,
and again,
if you think that we spend 30 billion,
uh,
from frontal money each year on basic research,
you know,
how much of death is used to kind of spread the word.
I think we were just assumed that by diffusion some of it will,
uh,
will flow.
And I think so.
So the best thing I can hope is that at least we have a serious discussion to
give answers.
Ideally quantifiable answers to the question.
Very good question that you raised.
So I'll do something a little different.
So I noticed a part of your biography that you're also a trained artist.
Think about that.
Well,
I'm a field artist.
Uh,
so,
uh,
so I,
I got my undergraduate in physics and then,
uh,
as my PC at Pfizer here to host a Nobel Prize winner said to Robert,
went to physics,
get board,
went into art school,
got even more bored and went back.
But if you're,
there's a little anecdote,
which I just think for me it was useful because I usually make the case that
actually suspend two years in art school does.
I learned how to do research and article because,
you know,
when I was a teenager,
I was the kind of,
uh,
the character that he,
perhaps many of you had similar.
And I've got to discover it,
the whole field of science and would take books and read and you know,
do the calculations myself and make drawings and everything.
And I went to,
to college and then of course you do the standard courses.
And I had very good grades,
but I was basically just focus on getting good grades and passing the test.
And that kind of lost interest in the field.
Uh,
I started painting,
then I went to art school.
I was very serious about that.
I think that's my career.
But when in art school,
I shouldn't been felt liberated.
I still remember the moment I walked into the bookstore,
I felt now I can buy a physics book again.
Uh,
so I bought Fiskville start reading it.
So it was like,
okay,
just this is for fun.
And then I felt,
wait a moment.
So there was something there.
But the nice thing in art school is that,
you know,
successful's not passing a test successful's at the end of the week if you had a
big stack of sketches and materials,
if you have just explored.
And so I made kind of a deal with myself and go back into physics because of us,
my first law.
Uh,
but I will try to conserve or preserve that approach of the artists at this to
say,
at the end of the week I wanted a big stack,
not have sketches but of calculations and just for fun you might get home,
tell my students always,
you just can't,
if you learn something,
trying to derive it yourself.
Finding a way to kind of internalize the result.
I do some crazy calculation.
Uh,
the thing I like best in art school was that you were forced to do things that
you didn't like.
You know,
I like to paint and I suddenly you have to do photography or printing actually
was fun.
It was liberating.
So,
um,
in some sense for me going this,
spending these two years in art was a shortcut to a research career.
And,
uh,
so I think that might be a lesson again that,
we are not always putting the right emphasis also in the way in which we educate
generations.
I think particularly in the sciences because now it feels like math and physics
and computer science,
it's so easy to a device,
a perfect test,
uh,
because it's so clear what the right and the wrong answers are.
Uh,
so we focus a lot about the right or wrong answers.
I think we should focus more on the right and the wrong questions.
So given the current political climate,
yes.
Where do you think the center of learning is right now?
Well,
it's clearly,
um,
there are lots of forces on it and I think it's not obvious that this country
will be to center.
So let's first think about,
you notice clearly there's a,
if you think of like research at this point is roughly equally distributed,
I think,
uh,
between North America,
Europe and Asia.
But a lot of things are happening,
but I would say to vary.
The top segment is still skewed.
It's still a large percentage is here in this country.
And I think what I feel about the United States has,
it has these kind of two wonderful characteristics that first of all,
a long,
long history of being open to other cultures,
other nationalities and other ideas.
Uh,
it's one of the few countries that's based on a very abstract principle and the
second ingredient is freedom.
So autonomy of individuals but also of institutions.
Um,
so both have been actually blossoming and no in some sense it's remarkable.
Uh,
flexing.
It was very critical about American universities and he predicted he had a very
dire future and he was like totally wrong because the,
these American universities will blossom and in the forties,
50s,
60s and now they're everywhere.
So he was wrong about that.
He was also wrong about,
that's large institutions couldn't be excellent because we have some,
we had places like Berkeley,
which were public institutions,
huge and you know,
top rank.
So,
uh,
the,
the local environment I would say in this country is really very well
positioned.
Also with a kind of a pragmatic,
empirical attitudes,
particularly for the sciences.
I think these days it's definitely is at risk because these two fundamental
points open to other ideas and other cultures and this kind of know this kind of
generous financial environment that's kind of makes institutions as we have here
in the Boston area,
a remarkable world leading institutions possible.
And um,
know the competition is eyeing these possibilities.
And you know,
we all know that Asia is rapidly growing.
Um,
and uh,
it's,
it's one of the most fundamental lessons of history to see that no commercial
centers and centers of learning,
they move,
they typically move on the scale of a century.
Uh,
I know that,
you know,
if you'd like to commercial center and I got some point,
it was in Venice and then it moved north to like Antwerp,
Amsterdam,
London,
and across the Atlantic.
So there you can see these movements on this kind of a scale of decades and
century.
And I think this country was both the beneficiary of a,
of geopolitics and,
uh,
and of course of this kind of a terrific financial support.
And both of these,
I think are at risk.
So I feel this is a very dangerous time because you're really,
uh,
no,
there,
there are many,
many,
many interventions can do,
but this is really kind of a,
something like open heart surgery.
You know,
this is really the crucial,
the crucial element that's kind of,
I think,
kind of pumps,
uh,
both the,
both the commercial and intellectual heart of this country.
And I think it's at risk.
And I wouldn't be surprised.
So in that sense,
even for Flexneri,
it wasn't obvious as he didn't write that it moved,
he said,
might move if you have a strength and,
and,
and will to do so.
So I think it's at risk and I think that's something that we should,
uh,
we should make that case very powerfully.
Yeah.
Thank you.
[inaudible].